in this course nishat Singh will teach
you how to integrate gpt3 from openai
with the react application you'll
basically be creating a website with
similar functionality to chat GPT
Nishant has created many popular video
and text-based tutorials hey guys
welcome to Free code camp
I am Nishant and I am your host for
today
and in this video we will basically
learn how to integrate opinion API with
react we will create two applications
and this one is the first one in this
application we will use openai API and
react to generate images using AI
for example if we type something like
this
and click generate an image it will give
us this image using AI so let's wait for
it we can see this loader and we have
this image which is loading it's
generated using AI this one was the
first application now the second one is
called charge Deputy clone
so you have much heard of charge Zippity
and what it does so it's a tool a very
powerful tool that can explain us some
code or give us some code if we type in
the prompt or you can give some question
answers if you give it a question
but we don't have options to integrate
charge apt into a JavaScript or react
app
but I have used some models from open a
API to create this application which can
give us some question answers based on
that knowledge or explain a piece of
code or all of this stuff so let's
create this as well so here I have a
react app with wheat that I created just
now
so let me clear the code a little bit in
app.jsx I went from this and remove all
this junk remove class name let me
remove this state of count and this
let's leave usted because we need it
later
also from the CSS let me remove the
black color
okay leave the black color we will work
on this
so let me explore this Service First
open AI API service
we have documentation overview examples
that you can explore
let's first login or you can sign up if
you want so it will ask you the email
address to create an account and all
so you can sign up so let me just go
back to open AI website let me okay this
one image generation
let me go to login and let me log in
with my email account
click continue
so in the process of logging in or
registering it will ask you
why do you want to use this API service
so you can choose that I want to create
my own app
only then you will get access and that's
how I got access to this open AIA beta
we have text completion code generation
completion whatever imagination fine
dining so I don't know the rest of
things
values imagination service here
all right so let me explore this how to
call this so we can click this click
documentation
then let's click libraries
here we can install this in
node.js so basically
we have to install it using this command
npm install open AI
let's install wait a second okay we
don't need this
dollar okay let me remove
now it will install and will be listed
in package.json file
C
this open a fine
let's also okay do nothing close it now
we have to import these things here
configuration and open AI
so let's so this is a module like es6
module so we have to use import so we
can say import
this I'll just do from open AI
inside we can have
configuration
comma open AI so open a API like this so
we have this two things imported here
now we need to initialize a
configuration variable called this
configuration
where it will take our API key
so
you can add your API key so let me add
my API key
create an API key from here API
reference
not from here let's see click this
person icon
view API keys
then just copy any API key from here let
me delete this
report key or just
okay we cannot copy so just rebook the
key
create a new secret key
we can just copy it
and let me paste it in EnV file
so in the source we can create
just this dot a e n v in the inv file we
have to use wheat and the
key name
and this EnV should be outside the
source folder before this we had it
inside in SRC folder so move it outside
and then simply decide the server you
will get the key here
of the wheat and I think we don't need
this
backticks or tablets little so we can
also remove this
okay now it's fine we don't need to
restart okay
so it is here so let me just copy
and
replace this with this key
now let's see what we have here next
in the
okay so let me go back to this image
generation
okay we have this configuration we would
note here we went there here
so let's see libraries okay so we have
imported this in ready Act
this configuration with the API key now
we have to use
this so we have to initialize one more
variable called open Ai and this will
contain
this open AI configured open AI that we
imported from open AI and it takes a
configuration that we created here with
the API key basically we are
initializing
our API open API open AI API
it's hard to pronounce open AI API fine
now we have this response
so
let's add this response here
so for this to work we need to create a
async function so let's create it so
const let's say get image or let's say
gen
rate image
I think the spelling of generate is
correct let me better Loop this on
Google I think
it's correct yes it's correct
generate okay
so you have to use your own API key
don't use my API key so in the generate
emit image function make it a sync
function
and just paste
this thing a weight
open AI dot create completion but it's
wrong this is for something else it's
for
like
uh
I think it's for
completing some text that we showed you
in the beginning
so instead we will use open AI
dot create image
create image this
and it will take not the model but the
prompt
and this things like n which is number
of images that we need to generate and
the size of the image like the
resolution
so we have this if we call this function
it will return us something
so let's say so in this response okay in
this note response okay we need to just
get the data in the response so we can
say const res or response then we can
simply console.log
this Ras
and
all of these items the list
let me copy this
and paste it here
URL I'm in the first URL
for this because we're generating only
one image
so now let's call the function
but before that okay let me just create
a button here
button
and say generate and image
on this button let's
assign this function so we can say on
click generate image we have this button
that will be helpful to or help us to
generate image so let's also do one
thing okay let's not do that okay so
create or generate an image something is
wrong open network tab
spending it will take some time like 10
seconds now if you open the console we
will have this
link here in the console so if you open
this link it will open up in a new tab
and you will see
the image that related to this prompt
say this is a test and this so it's
scrambled
so instead of this okay one more thing
when you generate the image
and then open manual account in your
daily API
its number and you will see that my
usage is this
so we get 18 credit
to use the API for free then we have
some charges
so if you see this Dali API usage
7 pm
okay
so we have basically some usage here
that we can track
if it is
like it is if it is expired you have to
use or have to pay
using our account
so find
so we have done this
so now let's create a state here and
what the state will do is we have to get
the prom from the input for that let's
create a state called
const
uh
prompt and set
prompt p r o m p t I must be here prompt
and set prompt so use state
let's say this is a string because it's
it's string
now let me create one input so we can
say input
here
we will have input but we need to
arrange them to div class name let's say
um
app
mean
now come over to let me close Envy file
come over to app.css we will write the
stylings here
so we can remove all of these click at
this okay something is
here that we need to leave I think this
class name yes fine the root last name
now let's say we have admin here copy
the class
come here over here and say
Flex or display of flex
then Flex Direction column
now we'll have this input and button now
let's style the input so we can say
class name
let's say app input okay now in this
let's say app input let's say height for
TPX but is too much let's try 30. okay
30 is fine
if we try 20 is also fine
we can type anything in here
fine
now let's give it some margin around
them or around it so 20 pixels
now we have this also let's add width of
200 pixels to make it big
like this we can type in here let me
Zoom this and yes this is perfect
perfect
let's give an H1 here
or yesh one here
generate and image using
open
a i API I think I am pronouncing this
correct now
yes sir
it's too big but
better to make it an H3 not H1
to decrease the size
okay now the design is broken
so we can say justify content
okay this will not work okay because you
know my previous video was all about
this
now it will look
see
okay okay okay okay
now what we gotta do is
so let me Zoom this okay we have this
text
so let me set the prompt from this input
so we can say on change
on change
we can
generate an event
and then call this function hit prompt
and store
this event dot targeted value inside the
state using this function
not validation message value
now this state which is prompt should
have this
so we can replace this
so we can add this as well and this as
well as a
input field or you can do that
find
and generate your image
now if you type something and click
generate image this will throw us a link
here in the
terminal or console list console
so okay let me also write a placeholder
here that
Place folder that says
enter or
type something
to
generate
an image
okay two dots
I think we have to make the size a
little bit bigger some big 400 too much
300 let's see 300 is
fine okay
now we have a place this as prompt State
now it will work so let's think of
something
let's say a
man
on a beach
now click generate an image
it will take some time so let's wait for
this
don't worry I will add a loader
or a text so we have this image now
click this link
and we will have image
a man on a beach like this
so it's wonderful
isn't it
I think it is
it is wonderful
and
so I think the usage of per API call or
per
request is 0.0 dollars
so we have 18 dollars that's
I think sufficient for testing
this otherwise if you can pay then you
can pay
so now what we have to do is let's
create
a image tag here
IMG tag images Source something
let's add Alt
something
save this but since we don't have the
source of this we will not see it here
so what we can do is
create one more state so let's say const
result and set
result equals to use date
empty string because image will be a
link in
text
so we can set it here not in so in the
console.log
so if you open the result
srcs link as a result it will be here
when we type
and generate the image
so it will you will see that the result
is
this
so we can just use
null is what is it called inside the
curly bracket it is called
knowledge Coalition I think
let's add empty string
or what we can do is we can say if
result
dot length
is more than zero only then show this
else show an empty fragment we can add
it here
so then we don't need this now save
now let's give it a try
so let's add
something else
a man
in a volcano this time not a mountain or
a beach volcano
click generate image
let's wait
for it to generate okay we don't need
the console
and we will get this massive image that
we can
make smaller we can say class name
result
image
just copy this class and add it here
and we can say
width
400 pixels that will be fine for 300
okay 300 is fine
some top margin so margin top 20 pixels
fine so we have this image
to spin
that's all I think I can make it 350.
that's fine
fine
if you click it again
this will generate a new image
so let's wait for it sometime
and you will see now let's spend things
or just say Mona Lisa
let's try this
it will take some time and it looks ugly
I mean this thicken this thing or
whatever it is looks ugly
so now let's
type something really different
uh I think let's say
let me think
uh
let's say a bird
riding okay not this let's say a horse
riding a
Diner Dino
car
now let's see what we get
this in this result
so basically this
Service open AI API generates image
using AI so whatever we type okay this
is not a horse it's a man
let's say a camel
riding a diameter yes so basically it
uses AI to mix images according to the
prompt so that's
what it is and I think it's a camel
riding a dinosaur but it's not a camel
it's still a human being but it's fine
all right so that's how we create
a service or a app and react that can
generate image using this new Dali API
from open AI API service
to generate image
for the second application we will use
child Liberty in our react application
we will use open AI models to do that
because we don't have any current
Integrations from chat jpt in our react
to Java step tab
so let's do that but first let's see a
glimpse of what it can do
so we can give it a prompt like this
explain Quantum Computing in simple
terms if we click this send button or
enter this will trigger
and it will start this answer
which is this
we can stop I don't think we're going to
stop
so
we can create different type of
conversation for example
when this is ends when this ends
we will have this named as Quantum the
beauty like this simple Quantum
Computing we can create a new chat
and here we can say what or how do I
make a JavaScript request using HTTP or
even fetch API now click this button
it will give you this answer
like this we can have several methods to
do all of these you can read this
it will also give you the code here
which is this
fine
so if it ends again this will be named
as the prompt how do I make and a stupid
request in JavaScript
so it will give you all the answers that
you need so it's a powerful app
see if it is now getting renamed so you
can delete this chat
yes and then we can get a question
answer as well like got any creative
ideas for 10 year old's birthday
if we click enter this will give us the
answer it can solve any problems or make
a list for gifts and do all the stuff
that you want it to do
fine so it's a yes a very good tool
I don't have to say more in this setup I
have a weight react app with nothing so
it's all empty but we have a commented
console log here so if you uncomment
this you will see the open AI API API
key here so let me show you
let me bring it down here okay now see
this is the API key that we have in the
console
so let me just comment it out
fine so
to get this key you have to create a Ana
file here and you have to add this
string wait open AI key and this API key
from open ai ai
API to get the API key simply go to
openai.com API
if you don't have any account Here sign
up or else just log in
so let me log in and show you the API
key
the source so you have to enter the
email
and this check so we need all the cars
verify
continue
then let me enter the password
and continue
so
we will see this page
now to get the key just go to this
uh this this this personal
and view API keys
here you have these Keys you can create
a key and get started to click the or to
see the usage you can simply go to
manage account here you will see the
usage so I have used
0.67 dollars of my
account from my account
the total amount I have is certain
knowledge which is free fine and it
expires on March 1
of the next year
so that
out of the way now let me go to the home
page
so we need to create a AI app in react
similar to what we have in
charge of it so let me open chat GPT so
we cannot use this in our react app for
now or in Javascript app because
we don't have the capability to
integrate it it's just something
exemplary or we can say
it is
what is it what is the word
it is
per
preview usage yes
so if you click the examples we will see
all of these categories like q a grammar
collection so we can use all of these
into our react app so let me show how to
do that so first let me create a
component here or first a folder called
components
in this folder let's create two files
first will be
uh
option
selection
Dot jsx
and second component will be let's say
let's say what can we call it
so let's say
what can we call the component
let's say translation
because here we will translate the
component so jsx like this
and so we have two components here
let me close this
so
now what we have to do in this object
selection we have to create all of these
options like this we see so make a
functional component here
and simply call or
random component inside
app.jsx into the main component like
this
fine now if you see the app we will see
this
text here
so let me remove this
uh just let me remove this div and make
a fragment from react
inside let's make an S one tag for the
heading which says
react
AI app
in bold letters if you want to get some
fonts just head over to
ponds.google.com
and get some funds from here
just paste this inside your CSS so let
me just
remove all
let me select pop-ins because it's my
favorite font
so we can select regular 400 italic
simple font medium 500 and that's all so
just copy all this using clicking this
icon here this icon silicate families
and just
just do what just copy
this import and paste this inside
the app.css
at the top
so we can remove all of these because
we don't need all of these
fine sorry move
and
to get the
text from H1 or in this font we can add
a class name and say
heading
inside this we can say heading
and font
ly
Poppins
save and this will be now in Poppins
font just like that
fine
now we need to create all these menus
menu items like small tabs so it's
better to create one
array
some mock data so we can say
let's create a folder called
uh
grid
or let's say AI
options
in this we can say index
dot j s x
sorry not jsx let's say Json
or what should we call it let's say jsx
fine
Javascript file and then say const
array items which will contain all of
these items in an array object so we can
say name
this will be
Q
and a so I will not use all of these
items I will just use a few of them like
q a grammar collection text to command
and all so we can say name then let's
say id id will be
let's see Q
question and a like this fine
let's say some
description
description in here we will see answer
questions
based on existing
exist in
knowledge
point so just like that we can create a
lot of these as much you can want or you
want so I've added a bunch of these into
the react app from this list you can add
more if you want but I have already or I
have just added one two three four
five six seven
seven pieces
so let's get the other items into our
app.jsx but first we have to export this
array items
now we can simply do import
array items from AI options from
that file
okay now we can simply console.log to
check what we are getting in the console
so you will see we are getting seven
items in the array now we can Traverse
through each item
so
let's just
add the array items inside
or just pass it as props into option
selection
because here we will select the option
fine now let me just map all these items
so we can say we need to create a grid
so we can say div first inside let's map
it so error items dot map
let's item
so we can say return
an empty fragment
in this we can simply have an H3 which
will be the title of that particular
item so we can see item Dot
let's say what is the key name that I
have added
the key name is called name
so item dot name
and second will be will be P tag
item dot description
we will get all these items
according to the array now all we have
to do is to
make them in a grid so we can say div
class name
let's say grid
Main
so we can just copy this
and add it here grid main display of
grid
then we can say grid template columns
Auto and auto to make them two in a row
but something is wrong here
okay let me open that index.css and I
have to remove something from here I
think
so let me remove all of these except
this one
but why it is failing so I guess we have
to add a div here
yes now it's working
if you removed it it will not be proper
but if I add a div it will be properly
rendered
so we are hitting this fine
now in this div give this a diva class
name of let's say grid
child because it's a child like every
item is the child here for the grid
so we can say grid child let's say let's
say the Border
or what we have here is nothing
so
what can we do let's make this an H4
to make it a little bit smaller
fine so we can say great child in this
let's say great child H4
let's add
um
font family Poppins
and font weight
600.
fine
what if we had 700
we need to make them bold but it's fine
now in great child
P tag
we need to add pop-ins but we need to
decrease the font size so we can say
font size let's say 15 pixels
hmm
let's remove this and make 500
it's not getting refreshed but why let's
add 12
yes now it's working
so basically let's make this an H3
and revert this back to H3 to make the
text bigger
fine
I think that's fine looking fine now
let's add a border
so great child
border
one pixels solid
white smoke color
like this
we can also add a gap between all the
items so say Gap 10 pixels
or 15 will be fine as well
now we need to make these
what is it we need to make the Border
curved around it so we can say
border radius
15 pixels as well
now they are curved curved what if you
make these two pixels yes now it looks
fine
so also we can add some padding to
sync the items
like this now it looks much better
we have react AI app title
and this also let's add margin top
20 pixels
to shift them
from the top
at 20 but
margin top 20
let's add 30 or 40 now it's fine yes
it's working
fine
now what we need to do is or let's do
something like this so if you hover the
titles or this card we should see a
highlight option so we can say first
cursor pointer now if you hover them we
will see this pointer cuts are here now
in the great child we can say dot Greek
child over
over
in this we can say background color
as white smoke and color as 2 1 2 1 2 1.
now if you save and if you now hover the
items we'll see this kind of thing
which is
I think great
fine
but something
should be checked here
so at app.css we are having all of these
items
Max width margin text align Center app
index.css okay this is the problem here
we have to remove font size from here
okay the thing happened okay leave it
fine so we are saying this
ugly looking items
now what needs to happen is
in this example so let's say you open
the first one called q a
so we have a
response this we have this like we have
this response which has model prompt
temperature and all
so we have to make them default for each
item
so to do that we need to create a
function
or we can do this as well so in this
app in this array of objects we can add
the model using an object so we can say
option
let's add option and this will be an
object
so for this q a we have to copy all of
these and paste it here and Save
but the problem is it will not plug like
that so I guess we have to do it from
here
I have to send it from here directly so
we can say
let me move this console log and then we
can say con or const
option
fine we have our error function which
will take option value
I mean option
param we can pass
let me okay I think that's fine we have
to pass this function as props to this
uh component option selection
so let's get it here
fine now if you click this child we
should trigger this
so we can on click
the select option
but I guess I have to add the items as
options here only then it will work so
let's add this just remove the prompt
because this will be dynamic
except the rest
so let me add this for now
so what will happen is if we click this
select option function using on click we
should send this item Dot
this key option
so let's do that
item dot option
now in here in the app.jsx we can simply
console DOT log this option
like this now let's see what happens if
you click Q and A at the top
we are getting all of these but we still
need one text area or input field for
these items
so let me show you what I mean
so click this click open in playground
we need something like this a text area
okay like this we need
fine so what can we do so in this other
component
translation.jsx let's create it
so RFC
let's save this
and
let's say import
translation from this component and just
enter it out here
translation
and we will see it here if you
close the console
but we need to see
the translation only when we have
selected the option
so let's create one state here so let's
say const let's say option and set
option
equals to use state
you state
and it will be an object
so we can set it here
like this when we click or trigger the
function so if we console
check in the console this option
initially we should get nothing I think
so let's see
see we are getting this object and it's
empty
so to check if it is empty we have to
convert this into an array so we can say
wrap this inside one parenthesis as the
object
dot values
and it will convert it in an array of
values from this and we can say length
if you refresh
we will see length is 0 it means the
error is empty or we have nothing inside
this object if you clear it and click
again it will be 7 because we will have
7 items inside the array to check we can
simply do this see we will have seven
items
so we need to show this translation
component only when
we have something inside this object so
we can say wrap this inside a curly
bracket to make it conditional
so we can say object dot value dot
option I mean objected values option
length
if it is 0 we need to show this
component
else we need to show translation
wait
if it is 0 okay
so refresh if you click q1 a you will
see this component now translation so
inside this let's add a text idea
text area
from HTML we have this so
we can style this so the class name
text area
we can also specify the row and columns
so we can say columns let's say four
to small let's say 40
and now that's fine we can increase it
make it 80. fine this looks fine and
let's also add some rows to increase
the height so let's say 40 as well
effort is too much let's add 30
okay 20 20 is fine we're gonna type it
inside it
so in the text area
we have to
change the font size so to make the font
bigger so we can say text area
Point size let's say 20 pixels
now we have this and it looks fine
so if you are making this font size 20
so we have to decrease the column so
let's say 60.
or
30 30 small let's say 40.
40 what about 50 50 is fine but what
about 60.
it stays too much it is going out of the
screen 50 is fine
also make this as 10. now this looks
fine correct
hmm
fine also we can add a little bit
padding here we can say padding
10 pixels
now we have this cool looking text idea
let's add the font size for different
memory of Poppins
to get the font in Poppins
you can also make this 55.
yes now it works fine fine
so this is done
now we need a button to translate
so let's add it
like to trigger the function so we can
say button
and say
do your
tough
now save
let's style the button to the class name
let's say
action button
action BTM
in the CSS
style this we can say width
uh 200 pixels
height 50 pixels
and font size 20 pixels
fine let's add margin top
20 pixels and that's all also cursor as
pointer
now we have this and this
now
the options are here
now if you click or refresh the page
you'll see this page
click this we will see this if you
refresh or let me do one more thing as
well
so in this translation let's also add
one more button to reset all of this so
we can say button it is set
it is set
reset reset
add the class name
here
but I guess we don't need that for now
so let's leave it remove the button
we'll just refresh the page
fine
so if you do your stuff
this should trigger a function correct
so let's say console
do
tough
and in this function
let's do something later so just first
pass it inside this translation
component as props receive it here
and make on change sorry on click
this function
also create one more state
for the input so we can say const
input
and set input
so use state and string
pass this as well here
in
translation component
receive it
or destructure it
then on this input of text area we can
see on change
we can say
it will take a param called e or event
and we can say or we can just store
event.target dot value inside this input
now if you type something
and check this state call input let's
see what we are getting
open the console
and type something and we're getting it
here so let's say we type hello we will
get hello here
like this
now
we are passing
let me open this we are passing all of
the options here
in this
function called option
so this is the object so we can append
this option like all of these options
with this text area input
to make the full set of this
to make a full set of this using prompt
so
we can simply just structure this
so we can take we can see options comma
let's say
prompt and prompt will be
this input
file so if you're not concerned along
the option let's see what we are getting
so open the console
like this options are here
but the prompt is empty see if you type
something like nishanth here
you'll see
from the still empty okay wait
so we need to set this in options
okay let's do this let's control DOT log
this inside this two stuff
now if you click those stuff you will
see this and prompt is still empty
hmm
yeah so I made a mistake so what we need
to do is we need to set the options from
this array object when we click the card
now if you console.log this let's see
what we are getting
so we are consoling the options so click
this and we'll get all this but we don't
have prompt here so when we need to we
need to use the prompt or set it in this
do stop function
so if we can do it like this no if you
type something in the
this text box
you will see this prompt here
now click the button do stuff and we
will see the prompt this
so let me start again
so initially this will be empty object
see
if you click
this card q a
we will get all of the items but not the
prompt
now click Nishant or admission here
it will say nothing
but if you click the do stuff button we
will see the prompt here as Nisha
so we are now having the full set
of the items now all we need to do is
translate this here
so let me
copy all of these items
so copy this configuration and open I
okay I need to install this as well
because I didn't install it
so we can say go to this
tutorial
how to install this
introduction
[Music]
quick start tutorial
no
let's say examples playground API
reference overview
let me figure out how to install this
because I am forgotten so to install
this simply open Terminal
and add this so npm I
open
AI
enter and it will install the open air
into our project that's all check the
package I sent to see if it is have been
installed or not see fine version 3.1.0
so close the terminal now we need to go
back to this quick start tutorial
we're not this try examples yes try q a
and now we need all of these items from
open AI so
we can import this
so we can say let's import them at the
top so we can say import something
from open AI
and
inside we can add configuration
and open AI API
then we need to create the instance for
this configuration just like it says
here
so let's create it here
and this will take the API key so we can
simply cut the apic from here and paste
it
the next step is to create instance of
this open AI using the API key and this
configuration so add it here
that's done and now we need to do is
this so in this function
we need to do all of the items so we
don't need to set options here we can
simply create one object so let's select
object
equals to
these items so cut this and paste remove
the state and if you now console this
options
or option let's see the result
no not option for the object
now let's check this click this nothing
will happen add some text like hello
now enter or press this button you will
see these items so prompt is hello and
all the items that we are getting
perfect
fine so in this
function
we have to add
the response and we have to make the
function as async
like this for asynchronous JavaScript
now
we need to park the object here not
these items
so we can remove this object parenthesis
and simply say object
now if you console.log this is response
let's see what we get
so just say CLG
response and I think it will work now
so let's start from the beginning
let's copy some question let's say this
let's paste it and see what we will get
click this
paste this question and say do your
stuff
so it will take some time so now we are
getting it
yeah so now we're getting it if you open
data we will see the choices in the
choices we will have the text
so let me just to respond dot data
dot choices zeroth index dot text
now we will get the entire text only not
some other thing
so try again and you will get this now
let's create one state called result
so we can say const
result and set result
equals to U state
empty string
now we have to store this response
inside this state and pass this as
props now you have to get the props in
the translation.jsx and add the text
after this text area
this so let's do that
so I have added this result dot length
if it is less than zero sorry more than
0 we will see result else will see
nothing or empty string I have also
added the model temperature and all all
the options in other
objects as well like grammar correction
like this now all we need to do is just
try this so refresh the page let's try
grammar collection
which is after q a
which converts the wrong English to
Standard English
so let's try this
do your stuff
and we will get this correct answer
so let's try something else
my
name a Nissan Note is we have typed a
now click do your stuff
we will see the both texts here she did
not go to the market my name is Nishan
if we add one
space or enter let's see what we get
we will get same thing it will not be
separated by spaces
so I think we have to do this
one space I think that's how we get
Space here
no it's backslash not forward slash
do your stuff
okay it's not working fine doesn't
matter so that's how it works
if you add one only it will give you one
now let's try other ones like
uh what is this
JavaScript to python code translator
so open this JavaScript to python
let's copy this code
and add it here
now click do your stuff let's see the
output here
so we will get the python code but
without indentation so that's fine
because I have not added Internet
indentation here
so we have an array called Docs
and we're pushing all the docks
for each into this car array dogs into
car ready
so in the python we can simply do
append.orgen this is how it works
fine
so I think this is done so we can say
translation of English to other
languages
so let's try this one at last
all right where is it
let's see
let me search for this
English to other languages
okay this is here
so
let's see this
translate this into French Spanish and
Japanese
so this text will be translated into
three items so do your stuff
we will see
this one is I think French this one is
Spanish and third one is Japanese so it
is working
so that's how we create so now you can
also create one react AI app there's
that does all of these things
dynamically
it can explain code or convert the code
to python from JavaScript or summarize
for second grader and give it some
answers
so you can go ahead and create this and
I think that's all like the video and
subscribe to my channel
thank you so much for watching the video